la última despedida entre viñas y flores
miles de japoneses despidieron al ex
primer ministro shinzo abe en una
caravana el cuerpo de abeer recorrió los
lugares más emblemáticos de tokio donde
realizó su carrera política como el
parlamento y la oficina del primer
ministro
no es que necesariamente apoyó sus
políticas o lo que sea pero como ha
estado en el poder durante tanto tiempo
creo que nos ha cuidado muy nada de
armas
el funeral se realizó a puerta cerrada
en un templo budista en el centro de
tokio con la presencia de un pequeño
grupo de familiares incluyendo a la
viuda aquí y el primer ministro en
ejercicio fungicida más de 2.000
personas participaron en un valor y el
lunes dentro de los asistentes estaban
el vicepresidente de taiwán y la
secretaria de tesoro de eeuu janet
selling el gobierno japonés informó que
se recibieron más de 1.700 mensajes de
condolencias de 259 países territorios y
organizaciones internacionales
fue primer ministro durante mucho tiempo
cuando yo era más joven el señor ave fue
el único primer ministro que conocí
estoy triste
sin suave fue primer ministro de japón
hasta 2020 ha sido el primer ministro
japonés que más tiempo ha ocupado ese
cargo ave fue asesinado el viernes 8 de
julio por un hombre de 41 años quien fue
capturado inmediatamente
según la investigación preliminar el
asesino fabricó el arma con la que
disparó luego de ver un vídeo de youtube